his newest movie is based on the James
Baldwin novel if Beale Street could talk
the film is about a young black couple
in New York City in the 1970s their
families come together to fight the
man's wrongful imprisonment amid a big
surprise what's going on
[Music]
[Music]
this is a sacrament and no I lost my
mind
we are drinking to new life tisha gonna
have Fanny's baby
[Music]
you
well not everybody's happy about 2/7
fontys beat that sounded started Mary
Jenkins is a director and also adapted
the novel he's here in studio 57 good to
have you back there yeah it's good to be
back there were many surprises in this
movie for me but first starting with you
I did not know that this was the first
James Baldwin book that had ever been
turned into a movie that I was so
surprised to hear that and you did that
yeah you know it's it's a shock to me
I'll shock to you - yeah you know I was
surprised to hear it as well but I think
part of that is just you know there are
many black authors who haven't been
adapted that should be James Baldwin Oh
Barry I know but Tony Morris has only
been adapted once Richard Wright I think
it's only been adapted once just so many
these literary Titans that haven't been
adapted so proof positive when I first
adapted this book um I didn't have the
rights to it I just took a trip to
Europe and decided I'm going to adapt a
james baldwin novel and then after the
fact realized oh in order to make this
film I need the rights that was when I
engaged with the James ball in the state
it's ultimately a love story mm-hmm but
it's also about false imprisonment
yeah it's set in the 70s but could so
happen today tell us about that yeah I
think that's the power of James Baldwin
you know so much about this book you
could take in Senate in 2018 which as a
filmmaker would be much easier for me I
can point my camera any direction you
know and not have to like clear a street
or clear a sign but it's me the power
and once the baldon was writing about
which just that he was telling the truth
was how these problems that persisted
you know and so to allow the book and
the film to remain set in the early
1970s to me I just spoke to the idea
that the family in this film could be
any family today and how do you address
that issue going after the justice
system while also telling a beautiful
love story you know to me it's just
relying and the the the very evocative
voice of James Baldwin you know what I
loved about this book in particular was
it asked this one voice of James Baldwin
which was very lush and sensual very
romantic but also at the same time just
as lush about speaking truth to power of
the injustice is that black folks have
always had to face living in this
country and I think when you take you
know they say that a story is the best
vehicle for an idea I think a
relationship is the best vehicle for
empathy you know and so I think the
tragedy arises because you see how
innocent and pure the love between our
two main characters are and it's able to
sustain despite all the things that are
gansan yes exactly exactly and that's
the amazing thing about this story can I
ask you a question we saw it in the clip
there there's a lot of space in this
film where there are silences and you
just hear the low music in the
background yeah what is that what's
going on there you know to me it was
about you know when I when I make these
foams none of them are autobiographical
these the ones I've made so far but I
often go back to memories of my own
childhood and you know I've never had to
tell someone that I was pregnant because
I'm not a woman yeah but I imagine it's
not something you rush into right and so
the space in that scene in particular it
was about Tish very slowly growing into
this announcement and then mom played by
Regina Kane going you know what I've got
this yeah and I think and when you watch
it with an audience in that space what
you see is people going back to their
own memories and the laughter just
spreads around the room and the scene
that on a surface seems very quiet and
very you know almost sort of like very
methodically paced it's just filled with
all these grenades of experience which
is what I love to do most as a filmmaker
it's said about you that you like making
people happy but you sometimes I have a
hard time with happiness yourself is
that true I think it's partly true I
mean I don't like that berry Jenkins I
know you know I need to sit to hell with
a therapist and my girlfriend and talk
about this a lot more you know King is
available she did wonderful couch in my
office she does you know I think it's
just something about you know we hold on
to our childhood it's quite a bit you
know a friend of mine said if you want
to really find a way to empathize with
someone imagine what they were like as a
child the most of things you carry into
adulthood are these traumas that we
experienced as a child so I think this
idea of happiness family community all
these things are very potent with me
because as a child I felt maybe a bit
outside those things you can come back
to this table any time because we'd love
to make you happy we love to see you
happy great work
those things make you a great writer and
director and all those things of great
empathy and understanding barry jenkins
thank you thank you guys if Beale Street
could talk will be released in select
theaters December 14th and nationwide in
January